stargate is going to have its own
channel
welcome to scitec your sci-fi tv a movie
channel
so excuse me for doing this video very
very quickly no green screen
um i've done here quickly for you but
that's about it um but this news has
come out and it's kind of thrown me
through a curveball to be honest i was
not expecting it now if you're a regular
side track you'll know that i have
people that i speak to that work in and
around mgm none of them told me this
deal was happening but what is the deal
well
pluto tv is available in america canada
and here in the uk is going to be
streaming stargate sg-1 sgu nsga and the
two movies
24 hours a day seven days a week from
april the first so that's basically from
friday coming
right what do i think of this news
one it's awesome because i haven't been
able to watch stargate if you want for a
while um it's only available in the uk
through um
prime but you have to actually pay for
it it's not even on the mgm um add-on at
the moment you have to actually buy for
serious now that's not actually a
problem because i've got the dvds um but
you know watching it through ease is is
nice
so that'll be great
it's also really great actually that
this does again show
how popular stargate is pluto doesn't
have a star trek channel it does have a
sci-fi channel and it does show star
trek over here in the uk discoveries on
pluto in the uk
um
but it doesn't show but you know
stargate has its own channel which is
very very cool
it does show again that amazon might be
planning to try to push stargate back
into our um memories getting new fans on
board
um
obviously mgm will be getting a fee off
pluto for this
but my concerns are
one it was completely unexpected
two pluto tv is actually owned by viacom
media networks which owns paramount
so it's kind of like
mgm have agreed to have this go on a
competitor
um
but i'm into minds about that as well
because it is a streaming service but
there's a different store to stream and
services stream service that is backed
up by adverts
and you can't watch it whenever you want
on demand you have to watch it basically
when it's on
and like traditional tv
and that isn't as popular nowadays
it does have um our access or people
came out about 500 million people can
access pluto tv
um so there is a big market there so i'm
a bit confused about what the strategy
here is now the people that i talk to in
and around mgm none of them are big
bosses none of them are in charge of
anything none of them would necessarily
know this deal was happening but i would
have thought they'd have heard rumors
and as far as i know i have sent
messages but they'll still be at work
now but i have sent messages to try and
say do you know anything about this um
but they've never mentioned it so i'm a
little bit surprised by that
i have spoken to them recently about
what their expectations are in the run
up to july date when the 25th
anniversary of stargate comes around and
they thoroughly expected stargate to go
on to amazon prime now that might still
be the deal
because this deal for it to go onto
pluto tv as well would have been made
some time ago i suspect that's why we've
been seeing stargate being removed from
other platforms is because this deal was
agreed and that would have been mgm on
its own agreeing that deal without
amazon's interference really
so it could simply be that that this is
a one-year deal which it happens quite a
lot nowadays as well the stream of
services will buy a show for like 12
months
it could be a one-year deal
amazon had nothing to do with it but
couldn't stop it um and anyway it's a
good way of getting stargate out there
um or this is part of a wider strategy
or my concern is
that this is because maybe
what we believed about amazon's
intentions of stargate aren't as true as
we thought
but i don't really believe that the
people i speak to in around mgm and
obviously what brad wright said what
joseph melosi has said um is that mgm
considers stargate to be a really
important for their future
and what i've been told is amazon
consider it to be um the sleep and giant
of sci-fi and they want it on our
screens in big new tv series and
potentially movies as quickly as humanly
possible
so i'm not quite sure how to take this
news but i'm not going to look a gift
horse in the mouth i'm going to just
enjoy the fact that stargate is on
a service now that i can access 24 7.
i can watch stargate and binge watch it
to my heart's content i haven't seen a
um stargate universe in a couple of
years actually in regular so that'll be
a joy
um and you know what this is great news
it's a good day so let's just take it as
a good day stargate is coming back it is
going to be on our screens 24 hours
seven days a week so let's just
celebrate that for now and not worry too
much about what it means just yet
so if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit that bell
notification and it really helps thumbs
up on the video not thumbs down even
though i've got no green screen i'm so
sorry um i've also recorded this on my
phone
and um
if you would like to support the channel
and you really can help us and become a
regular site tracker hit the join button
as always guys i'll see you soon and i
will continue to get this news out to
you as quickly as humanly possible
thanks very much see
[Music]
you